so what would getting bitten by just a
single tick feel like
well one of the scariest parts of being
bitten by a single tick is that you
wouldn't feel it at all one tick
drinking your blood would be the least
of your worries
ticks can give you plenty of other
health problems including Lyme disease
this tick-borne illness would make you
incredibly fatigued and could lead to
joint pain and heart issues
so yeah a single tick bite could change
your life
now if you ever find yourself walking in
some tall grassy Fields remember to
check everywhere on your body for ticks
afterwards and we mean everywhere
ticks can hide in your hair your armpits
and even your groin